we're gonna make a really nice light
sweet chilli sauce
first off your chili off with the top
in half and those seeds inside
are very powerful incredibly
hot but full of flavor
garlic two cloves of garlic
slice the garlic nice and thin so it
helps to puree
the chilies in the pest and water garlic
in
a touch of salt a little touch of sugar
in and then start grinding
push down first the salt and the sugar
really helps the puree the chili and the
garlic
fish sauce always a base to a chilli
sauce
two tablespoons in and a touch
of rice wine vinegar fish sauce gives it
the saltiness
the vinegar gives it a nice acidic
wake up three tablespoons of olive oil
nice mix that up beautiful look at it
the colors
incredible now spring onions i want the
texture
and the crunch spring onions in the
coriander
slice it once in
fresh lime and that goes brilliantly
with a red mullet
just really wakes up the chili the
garlic
and reminds the sauce that we're serving
with fish
now taste
wow that's delicious look at that
beautiful the longer that chili sauce
sits there
the better it gets now for the peanuts
and chili
that's gonna coat the top of the red
mullet
peanuts in salt
and that helps to really grind the
peanuts down some beautiful dried chili
flakes
creates a nice sort of warm heat
i'm using fresh chili for the sauce but
dried chili flakes for the coating
which will really crunch up when cooking
just a little bit of coriander
mix the coriander in to the peanuts and
look
i like them quite textured i don't want
them too small as a powder
otherwise they'll burn but crushed
lightly to coat the fish with the chili
and peanut seasoning
in a separate bowl beat two eggs along
with a splash of fish sauce
take your fillet lay in your red mullet
dip it in shake up your peanuts
and then in and make sure you push that
down cover that red mullet
up beautiful
now make sure that pan is really nice
and piping on if you put the fish in and
the pan's cold
all those wonderful peanuts and chilli
just gonna slide off the fish so we need
to sear it in and get it nice and crisp
in and lay away from you beautiful
[Music]
if the pan starts getting a little bit
too hot get your olive oil
and just place another teaspoon of olive
oil around the outside so it starts to
heat up
as it hits the center and it really
helps to stay so much more in control
and turn nice and gently
we want that nice sort of toasted
sauteed
crispness which adds a really lovely
flavor
tilt the pan and just baste
the top of the red mullet with that
really nice piping hot
olive oil you've got that really nice
roasted crunch
and it goes brilliantly with that soft
sweetness of that fish inside
get off and just leave them sitting in
there
and finish with lime and just go over
each one
now we'll take them out
and the sauce will touch on the bottom
and the tail of each fish
now to round that off serving some
fragrant rice
sauteed broccoli amazing and there you
have
a delicious peanut and crusted red
mullet
with a wonderful sweet chilli sauce
cooking with chilis isn't all about blow
your head off heat
this dish uses the exciting taste of a
chili but has a deliciously elegant
and subtle flavor
first off get that pan really nice and
hot these are
sirloin steaks sear it in the pan with
all that fat on
they'll add flavor salt and pepper
couple tablespoons of olive oil in
pan nice and hot hold up the steak
and lay it in always lay away the panna
a little shake and it stops the steak
from sticking we're looking for color
and if it sticks it's gonna burn
[Music]
while the steaks are cooking i can get
on with my super quick marinade
now two tablespoons of
misood paste that's a fermented soy bean
that gives a really nice sort of rich
sweetness
tablespoon of sugar a couple of
tablespoons rice wine
that gives it a really nice vinegary
kick a couple of tablespoons of olive
oil
salt and pepper i'm looking for a nice
sort of
thick rich marinade
marinade done it's time to turn the
steaks
sort the pan and to give the steaks
a little base all we're doing every time
is just adding more and more flavor
take your tongs and sort of lift the
steak on its back
and really melt all that fat down
offer the gas take them out
just take your knife see all that fat
there
just slice that off i don't want any of
that
now in to the marinade
[Music]
beautiful tacos are one of mexico's most
popular street foods
they've been made from beef pork chicken
or fish
and are loaded up with amazing sauces
and spices
now i want something sort of pickly
cabbage
these are chinese cabbages slice it
in half
look at it really crisp and really tasty
we're going to slice that into quarters
and then
just shred it and take your time
you think of cabbage here and you think
of sort of braised
cabbage nothing worse but at a taco you
want freshness
a little season of chili flakes they
sort of
discreetly give it a little bit of heat
a little touch of rice wine vinegar
if you haven't got that fresh lemon
juice
a small drop of toasted sesame seed oil
give that a really good mix
now i need something to sort of bring it
together we take some wasabi paste
very hot very spicy a sort of thumbnail
size
i'm gonna mix that with a couple of
tablespoons
of mayonnaise and give that a really
good mix
these are basic corn tortilla the trick
is
to sort of color them and then shape
them
actually place it on
the gas ring use some tongs
so it's not to burn yourself you can
also toast your tacos in a frying pan
from there i'm just gonna place it
on the rolling pin literally 30 seconds
as it cools down the great thing about
serving tacos is
people can fill them themselves just the
way they want them
cabbage just squeeze out wet marinade
a nice rustic little mountain
mayonnaise on wait you see
how soft and delicious and almost sort
of
melting in the mouth texture we've got
on this amazing sirloin
it's got that really nice sear around
the outside
it's just nice and pink in the middle
start off with my crispy shell back of
the spoon
with the wasabi mayonnaise inside
taco and just sprinkle that delicious
pickled cabbage and then just
start lining my taco three or four
slices
touch more of my spicy
layer and that is how i'd make
the perfect taco
chillis if you use them confidently they
can really add a new dimension
to the style of cooking but the real
trick is finding that balance of flavors
that really suits you
because that's the most important part
so this is the most amazing sirloin
you can see it's got that wonderful
marble for me the secret behind this
is cooking it quickly season the steaks
generously
salt and pepper push that seasoning
in to the sirloin take the soda out the
fridge literally 20 minutes before you
want to cook them so it gets up to room
temperature they cook more evenly
but more importantly you can actually
season right inside
the steak this little bit of fat down
here season that as well because that
is what we want to roast and get that
really nice and rendered
olive oil in a tablespoon roll that
round
as it starts to smoke in with the steaks
into the pan and lay away
again into the pan and lay away
if you don't hear that noise the minute
those steaks hit the pan
don't put them in so the secret now is
getting that color on the steak
turning it once and once only and
cooking it for two and a half
minutes each side what i want to do is
to get that
bit of fat rendered so it adds a lot
more flavor
just hold the steak down like that
and that starts to melt the fat which
makes it so much more tender
there should be no white fat left
anywhere
turn them over really important to have
that steak up to room temperature before
you start cooking it so the inside
is nice and warm so we spend less time
in the pan
and more time cooling down really
important
now two fingers touch
it goes in says rare i'm happy for them
to be rare because by the time i let
them rest
they're going to go back to medium rare
it'll continue cooking
out onto a plate and let them rest
one two
let's get my juices over
don't waste that really important
next the spicy dressing take the seeds
out of the chili to reduce the heat by
rubbing it in your hands
and tapping until the seeds fall out cut
it in half
and just chop it in
garlic and chilli works brilliantly a
quick way of peeling it
get your knife and just slam it down
pops out very very quickly in a little
touch of salt
rub start going around in circles first
you'll see it pureeing
nice clear that off now we've got the
heat in there from the chilli
and that richness from the garlic two
teaspoons of palm sugar this is where it
starts to have that nice
sweet sour effect
fish sauce fresh lime this is a simple
fresh chili dressing and it was
something i fell in love with
in vietnam and cambodia because it was
just
so easy give that a little mix
and dissolve the sugar quick taste
wow right vegetables a great fuss-free
way to get super thin ribbons of carrot
is to use a veg peeler when they're that
thin
they take the vinaigrette so much better
and radishes
just slice them down at an angle
lovely to give another dimension to the
salad i'm gonna use a banana shallot
they are incredibly mellow very sweet
across just chop up
the shallot and mix that through
want some sweetness in there now little
vine tomatoes
slice them in half smart is in
shallot radish carrots and tomatoes
next peel and slice cucumber chopped
spring onions
and shred baby gem lettuce and then
finally
get some fresh mint there's young men so
you don't need
to take all those stalks off all you do
is hold the bunch upside down
and then take it for a little trim
and just chop that once through
look at that nice minted
salad a couple of tablespoons of
dressing don't flood
the salad with the dressing we can
always add but we can't take it away
now really mix that dressing in there
make sure all that chili
and garlic and palm sugar wraps around
that salad
beautiful onto the plate
the steak's rested it's now nice and
medium rare
a little bit of fat we don't want to
find that in the salad
just slice that off that serves its
purpose
it's kept that steak nice and moist just
slice
going with the grain it's almost like
slicing through butter
and look inside beautiful
pink you slice the beef too thinly then
it goes stone cold
and more importantly all the goodness
runs out of it nice thick
slices get the beef and start
placing it around the salad take a
little teaspoon
of your dressing the rest of your salad
sip that on top
we'll finish it off with some toasted
peanuts peanuts in
now those nuts are really toasted nuts
on get another pan
and just crush
once they've cooled down just run them
through with a knife
they can hear how crunchy they are
another
texture another taste the salad
and then from there sprinkle
and then finally take that just finish
it with a little
tablespoon of that sauce and there is
one tasty
very well textured spicy beef salad
[Music]
you